[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce livre spécial consacré
à des auteurs qui sont justement
originaire des yvelines
grâce à vous le rendre un bon jour dont
jean patrice de le directeur de l'abri
du pavé du canal et vous avez organisé
c'était début juin une journée avec des
auteurs locaux ouf on peut dire ça c'est
ça tout à fait donc on a ouvert la
librairie durant une après-midi aux
auteurs locaux habituellement on avait
un autre format là c'était la première
fois qu'on essayait vraiment un salon
qui avait neuf auteurs locaux qui
étaient présents qui était venu là pour
rencontrer leurs l'ordonnateur c'était
une première pour certains pour d'autres
c'est une à roddick mais voilà donc
c'était cette première fois qu'on
recevait vraiment neuf auteurs qui
étaient locaux du cru qui
qui voilà qui voulait faire partager
leurs oeuvres et quand vous les avez
sélectionné alors en fait c'est plutôt
eux qui viennent vers nous voilà c'est
le dos et c'est comme ça que ça se passe
donc souvent l'auteur vient en libre et
10 ans et plus d'ici jeudi si j'écris un
livre
ma tante a beaucoup aimé mon frère aussi
mes voisins ont vraiment beaucoup
apprécié j'en ai vendu deux genres et
voilà et c'est souvent comme ça que ça
se passe et enfin des fois c'est mais
pourquoi mon livre à moi n'est pas dans
votre lien de ces souvent cette question
qui se pose alors après on essaye
d'expliquer comment ça fonctionne qu il
ya de la distribution il ya la diffusion
il ya des éditeurs il ya voilà il ya
tout un maillage qui existent pour qu'un
livre arrive dans une librairie
indépendante comme la nôtre mais après
donc il ya d'autres ponts de la
littérature où on ouvre forcément nos
portes et cette fascination les auteurs
locaux donc nous faut-il viennent on
relit si le contenu nous convient parce
qu'on reste quand même a déçu les
ouvrages qui se présentait dans votre
librairie ce n'est pas près de 60 d'ici
que voulez-vous l'énoncé facilement la
porte voisine c'est pas suffisant donc
voilà donc et on a plein de demandes pas
que ce soit dans la poésie la sf la
littérature la bande dessinée la
littérature jeunesse on a vraiment
beaucoup de choses quoi mais en
permanence toute l'année en fait on est
sollicité de parts de parler les auteurs
locaux elle avoue nous entretenons une
sélection de livres de deux de ses
auteurs qui sont venus chez vous des
vrais du pavé de kamal aimé y en a deux
notre voie qui étaient là mélanie sombre
un bonjour
vous êtes l'auteur du livre le double
monde aux idiots lance danza gaza qui
est ont en effet remis pour la jeunesse
donc vous allez nous parler de ce livre
est aussi de votre de froid autre
parcours et dany le frère bonjour nous
vous vous êtes aussi auteur d'un livre
pour la jeunesse qui se moule des trois
contes de perdre ans et c'est aux
éditions baudelaire
il ya je reviens vers laon c'est vrai
que j'ai douté qu'il est beaucoup
de littérature pour la jeunesse
notamment dans les hauteurs oui parce
que enfin là oui on a beaucoup enfin on
a plus de mal à trouver des essais de
sciences humaines mais c'est vrai que
beaucoup d'auteurs locaux fondent sont
dédiés à la jeunesse donc on a par
exemple ma main va au pot avec uri 6
quai carnot choupi un peu plus écrit
mélanie qui a commencé en fait à venir
chez nous par un roman animalier qui est
- eli et c'est comme ça qu'on s'est
connus en fait et c'est voilà c'est
comme ça qu'on a promu le premier puis
le second et on a suivi mélanie depuis
quelques années voilà j'espère le conte
de fées c'est votre combientième
parution alors le double monde on doit
être sûr là 12e ou 13e parution
effective cela
consiste au fait qu'elle ait pu dire
c'est pas très très drôle comme
expression bon alors vous êtes vous êtes
enseignante enfin la vie d'autrefois
dans quel mois qui enseigne en france
elle s'entend sans grande surprise le
collège lycée ou au lycée saint-exupéry
de montigny à montigny-le-bretonneux est
légalement
d'alfred ou alors je suis de mort pas
d'accord donc à quelques kilomètres
et vous êtes deux jours alors pour enfin
pape autre part compter de la vie mais
vous êtes un ancien militaire
quarante ans de carrière militaire voilà
maintenant retraité je profite à fond
mes petits-enfants et c'est eux qui
m'inspire d'ailleurs pour l'ailé pour
les fondre et ça s'est souvent seconde a
des ratés au projet des nordiques est ce
qu on pourrait raconter aux enfants
très exigeant papy raconte une histoire
papiers raconte une histoire alors bon
ils ont d'euros tous les classiques et
puis après il faut bien innover et puis
on se prend au jeu et j'ai fini par
créer leur en fonction de leur
personnalité de réactivité j'en ai fait
des petits rôles et intégrer un compte
et puis de fil en aiguille ils sont
amenés à vivre des aventures
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que sa demande
je crois que c'est michel tournier qui
disait c'est le le plus dur c'est
d'écrire pour les pour les enfants vous
êtes d'accord avec ça se dire qu'il faut
être à la fois
simple conseiller et pas raconter
n'importe quoi
faut savoir l'intéressé les règles et
les motiver mais bon et puis là beaucoup
comme des petits enfants eux mêmes et en
scène bon essai se prennent au jeu et
puis bon après sur l'âge et doté d un
une pure de lexique la fin de votre de
votre lit parce que ça m'a surpris il ya
des mots compliqués qui ne sont pas
d'usagé courant en fait la genèse de ce
livre c'est pendant le premier
confinement pendant l'école à la maison
j'avais commencé à écrire pour mes
petits enfants de façon leur faire
apprendre un petit peu de vocabulaire de
façon ludique à la maison et puis de fil
en aiguille bon mais l'histoire c'était
au fait je me suis laissé entraîner par
par leur faction cetera mais j'ai tenu à
ce qu'à la fin il y ait un lexique
justement un glossaire pour le
vocabulaire pour le français et puis
leur donne également quelques repères
historiques les inciter à regarder un
manuel d'histoire à regarder une carte
de france pour suivre les héros c'est de
façon un petit peu bien les les motiver
et puis qui va en tirer quelque chose
sur le plan scolaire on peut apprendre
quelque chose en lisant voilà une
fiction voilà un cd des terres
historiques on peut apprendre la
géographie on peut découvrir
la vie autrefois ça va être peut
reprendre
l'écriture pour enfants c'est pas parce
que c'est pour enfants que c'est que
l'histoire doit être simple ou que au
contraire je dois être simple c'est à
dire que on est dans sur un public en
construction un enfant c'est un futur
adulte donc on est dans l'apprentissage
dans la construction et et que ce soit
l'histoire en elle même le message et la
manière
de là déroulé et donc de la construire
de l'écrire et des termes qui sont
choisis effectivement sont importants
pour amener pour amener l'enfant à
grandir au travers de au fil des pages
oui c'est vrai que c'était des coups
durs complexes a
vraiment oui qui est souvent un
sous-genre enfin qui est plutôt noté
notifié comme ça mais non c'est non
absolument cci frère issa vrai travail
derrière
j'essaie seulement de faire à travers ce
livre une sorte de parcours initiatique
avec quelques repères quelques interdits
et puis leur donner le sens du devoir le
sens des responsabilités le coup les
notions de courage tu sais tout ça au
fil des pages pour les faire réfléchir
un petit peu plus les préparer à leur
vie d'adulte avec ce sorte de parcours
initiatique
mélanie quand vous commencez avec le
double monde vous savez exactement vous
allez vous laisser votre plume non je
suis pas sûr parce que j'ai construit
quand même je sais où je vais le double
monde c'est cape town hélas oui vous
avez au moins le premier le deuxième est
prévue pour courant novembre le
troisième est déjà écrit le quatrième
est déjà sur plan c'est à dire que dans
le deuxième déjà écrit de leur album
bien sûr dans le deuxième et écrivent à
boyer en novembre l'autre tenir les déjà
écrit le quatrième est déjà sur plan
c'est à dire que je connais des plans
donc à huy sujet des plus riches aux
lettres sur blanc ce n'est pas en nous
qu'on se faisait pas une maison mais
c'est ça c'est le plan pas pour pas se
perdre dans ses idées et dans ses
personnages mais également dans la
logique qu'on veut insuffler
à l'histoire et on parle bien d'un
endroit pour arriver à un autre et le
chemin à prendre
peut être parfois un petit peu compliqué
peut-être parfois le modifier certes
mais on a ce fil rouge
en tête qui permet toujours de rattraper
voilà de se rattraper et d'avoir scellé
leur un peu et puis de semer des petits
indices au fur et à mesure du texte
qu'on peut ensuite comprendre
plus tard et qu'on voit beaucoup mieux
dans une deuxième lecture puisqu'un
livre idéalement faudrait le dire deux
fois une première fois pour le découvrir
et une deuxième fois pour trouver un
accord et voilà et se dire ah mais oui
en fait il y avait cet indice là mais
c'était c'est évident et c'est ce qui
peut nous arriver en dans un certain
nombre de livres ceux qui sont à lire et
à relire il y en accompagnement de
l'éditeur ou est ce qu'il ya une
relecture de ce manuscrit toutes les
filles entre lecture on a des échanges
l'éditeur le premier lecteur sait
glisser votre éditions si vous aidez
enfin ces confrères c'est mon frère un
autre frère voilà mon premier lecteur
c'est mon frère qui m'a vraiment
beaucoup suivi sur le double monde pour
maudit pour suisse voilà c'est mon frère
donc ils n'hésitent pas à me dire oui ça
c'est terrible ça ça va il le dit assez
franchement donc ça me permet vraiment
de discuter avec lui de voir où sont les
points qui serait améliorée parce que
faut savoir que moi j'ai tout dans la
tête donc moi c'est évident mais une
fois sur le papier peut y avoir des
certains passages qui à l'écrit
lecteurs ce n'est pas
parce que c'est ça et pas tant que ça
alors là j'ai pas bien compris ce que tu
voulais dire effectivement je dors
travail et c'est une version beaucoup
plus aboutie que j'envoie les goûteurs
qui le renie qui retravaille kim la note
en avec des passages éventuellement
reformuler à développer
a donc à retravailler et on a un échange
un va-et-vient avec l'éditeur assez
important pour pouvoir
je pense que c'est très important ça de
préciser le travail de l'éditeur en fait
parce que souvent les auteurs locaux
arrivent avec un manuscrit très peu
travaillé et très peureux lui et il ya
très peu de talent d'auteurs locaux
finalement qui se font ce travail bien
fait et dit adorer ça on en viendrait
mais voilà peut-être après ça c'est
vraiment moi l'élite s'est pas lassé pas
forcément évident belani comment est née
justement de vous dites quatre tomes
donc c'est un travail important comment
est née l'idée
de ce travail et de ses romans et et
peut-être peut-être nous raconter
peut-être ou téléspectateurs très
rapidement de goût de quoi de quoi ça
parle alors le double monde et nous ya
très longtemps dans ma tête puisque
j'étais encore au lycée oui oui oui
cet été air bien sûr s'agisse ya deux
ans le lycée nous et il va laver a donc
vous aviez déjà cette envie de créer
décrire cette idée mais j'ai une idée
que j'ai commencé à développer
j'ai commencé quand même à mettre sur
papier
je me suis arrêté à une cinquantaine de
pages que j'ai mise j'ai mis toutes ses
pages en tiroir et j'ai laissé les trois
ferme et moi j'ai fait mes études
souvent ça c'est les auteurs balancer
des trucs et puis d'arrêter et puis
j'étais jeune j'ai fait mes études de
littérature
est un peu plus tard j'ai ouvert le
tiroir j'ai redécouvert le manuscrit je
me suis souvenu de cette idée je me suis
dit c'est vrai que j'aimerais bien
développé cette idée j'ai relu les pages
j'ai vu que j'étais jeune ça veut dire
que les u11 qu'il fallait peut-être les
retravailler tomber raide et tenez voilà
mais l'idée c'est l'idée que j'ai
conservé ma douleur oui alors c'est une
c'est une jeune fille qui a 16 ans qui
se sont plus ou moins bien dans ses
baskets dans son quotidien elle n'est
pas toute seule elle a des ailes à elle
a une amie mais elle se sent pas
toujours intégré manque de confiance en
elle voilà une fille assez
ordina d'eau assez ordinaire qui un jour
fait se retrouve projeté dans un autre
monde et demandent donc il ya deux
mondes et dans ceux dans cet autre monde
on l'attend avec impatience
on lui donne immédiatement ce statut
d'élu
avec une responsabilité assez importante
puisque lui demandent de les aider ce
peuple qui s'appelle le peuple et des
mines cas à sauver sauver ce nouveau
mode donc là elle est un peu dubitative
déjà comprends pas comment c'est
possible et elle se sent pas du tout la
stature pour
elle a déjà du mal avec elle même dans
sa propre vie donc autant dire qu un
peuple entier ça fait beaucoup et c'est
vraiment cette démarche de voilà deux
dalles et de croire en soi de prendre
confiance et puis de devoir ensuite
c'est faire des choix prenez ces
scissions mais c'est génial parce que
via là on est dans une époque où parle
beaucoup du metavers c'est à dire d'un
monde virtuel dans lequel on va par et
il a évolué
vous avez inventé ce avant tout le monde
je sais pas si j'ai inventé ça avant
tout le monde mais on est dedans mais la
voilà des frères alors vous vous disiez
moi je voulais raconter des histoires
mais mes petits enfants comment ça se
passe aussi l'écriture
vous réécrivez beaucoup vous savez où
vous allez exactement au départ j'ai une
petite idée en tête et puis c'est en les
observant
bon j'ai trois petits enfants j'avais
même temps fort dès la 4e mais l'époque
ils étaient 3 2 qui sont en
ile-de-france frères et soeurs et leur
cousin qui est
qui avait passé quelques temps à lyon et
qui parti ça c'est là sans voix il ne se
voyait pas souvent est bon les deux que
j'ai pris deux mois passent leur temps à
se chamailler donc en les voyant on dit
il faut que je trouve un moyen de les
relier puis de faire que ce poids là
j'ai mis en scène j'ai fait un premier
compte mais d'en scène les deux premiers
qui à la suite d'une brouille vont se
séparer vont faire chacun de rencontre
qui va transformer leur vie ma petite
fille va rencontrer un
pion mousquetaires ne ses mousquetaires
mon petit fils un ancien art chez le psy
leur activité ma petite fille fais de
l'escrimé en activité extrascolaire donc
je vais trouver un rôle à sa mesure
elles devenues championnes des scream
son petit frère jean couty relaxe et
puis de fil en aiguille et bien ils vont
être amenés à se réconcilier parce que
face à un danger commun et puis ensuite
ils vont contacter leurs cousins qui va
les rejoindre lui qui aime les enquêtes
qui aiment les énigmes et bien
les trois jeunes vont conjuguer leurs
talents pour petit à petit des jouets un
premier complot contre le roi qui a un
second complot pour suivre des voleurs
et en mêlant également des souvenirs de
vacances en particulier ne randonnée en
montagne
et
donc le décrit en décors naturels et ils
sont fiers dans dix enfants baby foot et
je pense que il se retrouvait sur ei
salaire ils se retrouvent de dorval et
alors même question qu'est ce que vous
avez comme une amie vous avez un éditeur
qui relie ou quelqu'un qui est le
premier lecteur séguy alors le premier
éditeur s'était d'abord mes petits
enfants ensuite bon je ne pensais pas du
tout aller jusqu'à la publication parce
que c'était purement familial mais si
mon fils me dit papa écoute là tu as
quelque chose qui pourrait peut-être la
clé la même chose donc oui voilà et puis
bon j'ai été conseillé par mois aux
libraires qui j'allais donner le
manuscrit puis du médium ses frères là
franchement vous devriez
voilà et puis donc j'ai eu une liste
d'auteurs j'ai collé le premier j'ai
compté kns d'éditeurs et le premier j'ai
contacté me répondit d'écouter celles
éditions baudelaire éditions baudelaire
voilà
comment justement l'un et l'autre koala
donc vous avez contacté puis ça ça a
marché très vite voilà et vous comment
comment ça se passe et le contact avec
l'éditeur alors
les premiers j'ai beaucoup de refus tout
au début il faut être patient
ensuite j'ai je suis entré chez yvelines
édition record dans avec les premiers
donc les premiers petits romans
puis chez lance daly édition le premier
que j'ai publié c'est le secret de la
carte postale d'une petite enquête qui
se déroula à royan l'osdl c'est quoi
comme gommer une
maison d'édition qui est dans les hauts
de france d'accord
forcément il ya beaucoup de littérature
jeunesse mais on traverse les âges invs
à cause également de la littérature
adulte il ya un petit peu voilà il y en
a pour tout le monde
et si je me trompe pas il ya même des
romans graphiques on est vrai qu arthur
sur une maison d'édition qui se
diversifie au fil du temps
l âge et envoyez donc un premier
manuscrit qui a été retenu puis un
deuxième donc qui n'a princesse coeur
rebelles et le troisième le doublement
qui la part sur la quatre voies sur
quatre tomes bien évidemment et les
éditions baudelaire s'est dit un peu
tout de plus tôt alors oui mais vous
sélectionnez voilà ils sont deux tours
au vent poésie ils ont leur gamme assez
complète de en littérature bon ils sont
implantés à value leur siège social est
à lyon d'accord et est ce que comme guy
laurent tout à l'heure quand vous
publiez un livre vous allez vite voir
les débris s'il est bien en place parce
que tous les auteurs sont toujours déçus
alors que la revivre leurs livres
comment voulez vous qu'on l'achète
personnel le monde d'édition notamment
quand même très très très vaste et bon
les grands éditeurs abreuvent les sens
même que les libraires commandes la
preuve les mais bon pour les petits
éditeurs ou d'éditeurs un peu plus
modeste là il faut effectivement faire
un petit peu de porte à porte
puis elle a rencontré deux libraires
présenter son ouvrage puis
et il ya un rayon donc non spécifique
aux auteurs de des yvelines non non non
on a décidé les interclasses mode c'est
la poésie sonore le poésie quand en
jeunesse mélanie attend jeunesse daniel
et en littérature jeunesse également
voilà non non c'est vraiment été
reclassé quoi mais c'est vrai que
souvent l'auteur vient avec un
argumentaire plus ou moins rodé et voilà
des fois c'est me comprends pas bien
comment ça fonctionne alors donc comme
les livres qu arrivera en librairie chez
nous on les a tous sélectionnés aucun
éditeur ne poussera aucun lieu donc mais
c'est vrai que baudelaire par exemple
fait de l'impression à la demande n'est
pas diffusé en librairie indépendante
donc la bande au goût c'est pas du tout
diffusé
il faut que ce soit l'auteur qui fait se
souviennent la tournée des librairies
landes soldes je sais pas du tout ils
sont diffusés oui d'accord donc voilà
c'est vraiment les petits éditeurs ont
du mal à rentrer dans le jeu vraiment
beaucoup alors il y avait il n'y avait
ni avait pas que dans cette
manifestation qu'ils avaient organisée à
la politique à dame
voulait parler de nous présenter un deux
trois livres sous là bas nous avait
parlé toute la wii tout à fait vrai
alors je sais pas si on le voit bien
donc qui est un peu le pendant de
t'choupi mais en beaucoup mieux plus
écrit pour le coup tordu 03 ans voilà
donc pour ici qui vient fréquemment à la
librairie également et ça fait trois ans
maintenant qu'on a ces ouvrages megan
est toutes ces nouveautés sont aussi
présentes donc voilà et sans ce enfin ce
sont des petites librairies comme noël
serait pas durer six à deux non plus
quoi c'est compliqué c'est compliqué la
vie d'auteur est compliquée dimanche
mais même pour les acteurs installés ego
n'y a pas la place pour tout le monde
que la production est tel que forcément
nous on fait des sélections donc oui oui
c'est ça c'est un peu compliqué pour
tout le monde comment se passe la
période justement pour le livre
l'actuellement 2021 était tellement
étonnant est exceptionnel que l'on on
reprend un peu de normalité c'est grâce
jeremy dear grâce au confinement grasset
a besoin d'être tout à fait non c'est
que les gens avaient ils besoin de
niveau de la culture il y avait plus de
consommation autre que le livre il y
avait les théâtres et et fermer les
cinémas étaient fermés et les musées
l'était également donc les gens se sont
vraiment recentrer sur la lecture dont
2021 était vraiment exceptionnel dans
tous les sens du terme au niveau de la
production au niveau de plein de choses
donc là 2022 reprend on reprend le nom
normalité mais qui reste quand même reçu
2019 donc ça veut dire tout ce qu'on a
pu emmagasiner durant ce confinement là
on en a quand même conservé une part
donc non les librairies supporte la
lecture également et puis maintenant il
ya le pass culture qui vient aussi louis
nous aider et ça marche bien ça marche
bien ça marche bien dans les librairies
de 10 et un peu avant l'émission et
c'est vrai que c'est surtout le manga
qui profitent du pass culture oui mais
lire un manga c'est dire et bien non il
ya aussi ce à quoi parce que
habituellement ils ont pas vraiment les
cotes rentrée en libérer indépendants
ils sont un peu perdus nous on sait pas
non plus toujours bien les recevoir nos
voix au moins voilà il ya quelque chose
qui se crée donc le jeune de 18 ans
vient en librairie discutent avec nous
donc oui mais effectivement c'est
beaucoup de langues à mélanie est ce que
vos élèves savent que vous écrivez
certains oui alors qu'ils évoluent j'ai
découvert cette année oui-oui à
certaines heures cette année ils ont
découvert pour certains que j'écrivais
donc ils ont lu me l'ont d'abord lu
avant de me dire puisqu'on nous voir
après en me disant madame j'ai lu votre
livre les au b2b oui
non j'ai même eu un vautour on affronte
hommes de maintenant a
donc ça commence c'est à dire que
j'arrive pas en classe en dix ans
j'écris j'arrive plutôt en glace avec
vraiment cette casquette d'enseignante
et ses impôts fur à mesure donc c'est
souvent au fil de l'année vous en saisie
et qu'elle période si je veux dire dans
la littérature enfin la période qu'on
nous demande des enseignants programme
c'est quoi
dans ma ça dépend ça dépend des classes
toujours bien sûr ah bah ça va en
sixième on a déjà des textes sur la
mythologie détecte à l'antiquité
jusqu'au xxème siècle selon david dans
les
salons les perles donc c'est assez assez
large qu'est-ce que quels sont les
auteurs qui vous aspire vous
si un auteur pour la jeunesse notamment
fortement pas forcément moi j'aime
beaucoup alors j'aime bien re lire ou
relire certains certains livres qu'on
dit classique vraiment puis de toute
manière vaut mieux que je le relise
puisque on travaille dessus en classe
donc il ya vraiment une connaissance et
une transmission qui à fait intéressante
j'aime bien également lire les livres de
mes élèves donc les livres pour ados et
parfois d'assez ce que j'ai fait aussi
cette année j'ai une élève en 1ère qui
m'a prêté un livre qu'elle est mais je
lui dis bah elle est entrée venir en
classe j'ai débattu ces traitements un
livre que tu aimes bien elle en a prêté
un jeu l'élu et on a ces échanges la
alors dit souvent que là j'essaye de
faire aussi une petite boîte de lecture
où les voix de lecture plaisir c'est à
dire que c'est une boîte de lecture où
chacun met au niveau des jeux plus
qu'inutiles voilà qu'il aime pour que
les autres élèves puissent également
qu'il ya un échange autour de ses livres
mais c'est pas des livres voilà que
j'impose ou que c'est vraiment des
choisi qu'ils ont dans leur bibliothèque
qui ont envie de partager avec leurs
amis et de créer des échanges autour de
la lecture un petit peu de la sorte mais
voilà sortir aussi parce que c'est sur
moi j'arrive et je leur impose des
livres
qui n'ont pas forcément envie de lire
certes donc il ya sept des transmissions
pouvoir la montre je peux
leur voix la littérature l'intéressé
texte mais j'aime bien aussi les amener
vers ce plaisir de lire pour qu'ensuite
plus tard ils puissent en train dans une
libre et à des magasins
n'a t il rien et pouvoir c'est ça la
formation font un oui tout à fait vous
donnez à la transmission soirées du goût
de la littérature des arts goût de la
littérature et du livre et pas pour qui
forcément qui me lisent des classiques
toute leur vie mais pour qu'ils ont tout
simplement registre est allé vers aller
vers l'objet livre
daniel frère vous avez des auteurs qui
vous je suis éclectique j'aime les bons
tous les grands auteurs du 19e les eaux
l'année tu resteras j'ai un grand faible
pour les romans historiques
étoffé avec fond historique très riche
still
life bleuse romandie de denis tiers ou
louisiane de derrière ou alors les
romans de jean d'aillon ils sont très
riches sur le plan historique
et puis les auteurs qui ont également
beaucoup d'imagination comme tolkien où
l'accord bayard il a aussi un autre
monde c'est à notre
écoute et de merci infiniment bravo lors
pour sauter ce type se fait voilà ça
fait sale nom en valeur voilà des
auteurs qui et c'est difficile toujours
d'avoir un contact avec des avec les
lecteurs c'est très bien de laisser le
rôle enfin c'est drôle de libraires
indépendants de chacune des villes font
voilà on est un acteur tu le sais la
fameuse l'image du canal merci beaucoup
d'années le frère je rappelle le titre
de votre livre des trois contes de
perdre on a sept éditions baudelaire et
mais des légumes et l'a dit jean brun
laid le double monde aux éditions l'ours
d'argent c'est ça merci à tous les trois
la merci
[Musique]